it feels like it's been ages since I
last uploaded so I just felt like having
a bit of a chat around the current
happenings in the division franchise
I have actually been working on a couple
of projects in the background but I
can't really talk about these right now
take that as you will but long story
short I actually miss uploading when
it's been a while
don't expect any hugely in-depth law
discussion here I just felt like having
a chat no idea where this will end up
going I just have a couple of bullet
points in front of me so yeah let's see
what happens
we're over halfway through the season 11
Manhunt with the next Target cursed
being available to hunt down in the next
couple of days
chunks and Batman Bantam band no Bantam
uh they played out in a fairly typical
fashion with no real new gameplay
surprises to be found but the Intel game
through completing them did open up some
further crossovers between the game
story and the novels which I personally
really appreciate most of the time
companion novels are just an offshoot or
a side story where these are shaping up
to be far more involved with the
Direction the Story is taking it gives a
more complete feeling when reading
through all of these different media
types so kudos to Lauren Stone and
Thomas Parrott I love this shirt please
keep it coming
stovepipe is still there with a smug
smile and pointy ears and beautiful hair
but I don't imagine he'll be much of a
problem actually that's a point the last
several manhunts I've seen people
complaining or talking about how
difficult they were and I'll admit they
certainly were more challenging than the
normal content personally I love it I
generally play on heroic with four to
five directives anyway so I welcome the
challenge but now I'm seeing complaints
that this last Manhunt was too easy I
guess this is just another situation
where the devs will never be able to
please everyone and some people just
really like to have something to
complain about
I also think that this is a little bit
to do with a certain talent that is a
tad overpowered right now it doesn't
matter what build you're running
determined makes everything super easy
and no I'm not trying to be canceled by
the community for requesting a Nerf Etc
they're already aware of this and have
said changes are coming to be fair it's
taken all the fun out of sniping the
satisfaction of Landing five crisp
headshots in a row is lost where now I
can just quick scope without bothering
to aim shot him in the pinky no worries
he's dead and it still counts as a
headshot in fact the footage in the
background is me playing around with
different combinations in the dark Zone
one shotting via body shot with the
white death is actually stupidly easy
over 2 million armor no problem and
saying that I'm not a division PVP
player by any means I just like to play
around with these things you know for
science
at this point I should probably shout
out the poor bastard that has to put up
to the brunt of my stupid ideas alpha
bravo is a friend of mine in real life
and he is in the unfortunate position
that often has me testing a few builds
but also the weird random challenges I
like to run from time to time
you should probably feel sorry for him
the poor guy just wants to jump on for a
night of gaming yet here I am saying
things like wait wait wait do you reckon
we could ride the Doggers around let's
try or let me see you on fire I want to
see if it'll spread to those agents over
there
he's actually started his own YouTube
channel recently so as a thank you for
the hard time that I give him can you
please check him a sub also you'll
probably see some slightly different
content in the future including me in a
more raw setting making an ass of myself
on the regular so you certainly don't
want to miss that he's just starting out
and still learning so give them some
feedback and watch them grow I'll catch
you over there soon
we're not far off from finishing the
season 11 Manhunt and this was the last
confirmed update for year four year five
is almost upon us
they've been pretty tight-lipped about
what we'll be seeing in year 5 but there
are a few things we should be looking
out for the new descent game mode
New Seasons with a new naming convention
which I'm sure will confuse me a little
to start with
an XP revamp which will happen across
PVP and the main game some activities
will have the XP decreased but for the
most part everything is being increased
making activities more rewarding for the
time spent on them and finally the
specialization rework they've been
working on this for a while and it was
supposed to be out a long time ago now
but they've publicly said that their
plan changes haven't worked out as well
as they were hoping for so they're
putting a little more time into it
this is all that we know they are
working on but there is likely a lot
more that we haven't been told about yet
the live stream is coming up and
hopefully we'll fill us in soon
a few days ago this was tweeted by the
official division franchise Twitter
account
upon signing up you'll be asked the
typical questions around preferred
platform gaming time per week gaming
genres but also preferred play style and
difficulty
this doesn't really give a lot of
insiders to what they wanted to test but
there are a few things to be sure of you
must be English speaking have a mic
webcam a PC and be available on certain
days between April 18th and 21st
yes I can already hear the complaining
from console players but the way this
play test works is that users are to
remote login to massive species
something that can absolutely not be
done by a console
given its timing I guarantee that this
is something to do with what's coming up
in year 5 content
I have absolutely signed up but these
sort of things are tricky yes I want to
be involved but then I know too much and
can't talk about it a bit of a catch-22
anyway if you're on PC and those dates
work for you sign up Don't Leave It to
the YouTubers to provide all the
feedback
another topic that has been marginally
interesting to follow has been the
outrage behind this message
I'm not going to sugarcoat this I hate
cheating hacks exploits and leaks
some of my favorite arguments that I've
read are things like well they
programmed it into the game to allow us
to do it so it's their problem not ours
ban the divs imagine if Society ran this
way well their store security wasn't
good enough so I just took it just
because you can do it doesn't mean you
should
in other is this doesn't affect anyone
else they should just leave it in the
game but this trend thought why don't
you just download some hacks that way
you can just fly around the map
one-shotting everything as long as
you're only using it in PVE that should
be fine right
I don't know maybe I'm just old I was
around in the Heyday of Playstation 1
cheat code websites the cheats were
literally programmed into the game yes I
tried them and yes I completely killed
the game for me as soon as I use them I
don't find it odd that developers don't
want this to happen these days
I actually don't blame the players
people as a whole are inherently lazy if
there is a faster or easy way of doing
something they'll jump straight on board
I'm more blame the YouTubers who promote
them they are the ones who spread it far
enough that problems like this happen
I would like to see these people being
held accountable instead of being
rewarded
I know for a fact there is one Conte
Creator who openly hates on the game
spreads exploits resulting in community
members being banned and yet is invited
to partake in the exclusive ETF that has
the potential to shape the future of the
game
this is where I place the blame on the
Developers
I guess just be cautious who you follow
Sam will care more about the views and
less about what happens to the community
I could never be accused of using
exploits I'll put a stupid amount of
time to the game and I've only just
crossed 3 000 shd level
I think I spend too much time trying to
take photos of my character fighting
fire or finding new ways of using words
that are inappropriate for my
unfortunate accent
and that is where she puts up her final
stand on the ship's long rugged slippery
deck
Yep this video is just another one of
those off-brand pieces where I talk
first and sync later it's actually ended
up being a little longer than I'd
imagined the power of having no script
like this
I realize that I'm unlikely to have
gained any friends among the YouTuber
Community because of this but I've never
really been quiet about my thoughts
around the way that some grow their
channels at the expense of the games
developers and the community
don't get me wrong though there are a
number I respect but they're often on
the smaller side and don't get the views
they should
I completely understand the need for
growth hey I need to see it myself too
but to hyper dramatize click bait or
exploit all in the name of clicks I
won't be quiet about this
anyway I'm thinking that I might start
spotlighting some of the Lesser known
division creators at the end of my
videos
I recently started watching some smaller
creators and I've been super impressed
with what I've seen the equality gives a
number of us larger creators a run for
our money and I love to see it if you
have anyone that you follow who is on
the smaller side that you think I should
check out please let me know in the
comments
otherwise thank you very much for
watching I'll try not to make a habit of
these runt videos where I sound like a
grumpy old man but um I'll catch you in
the next one cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
hahaha
[Music]